اسمه وولف شميت وهو مواطن دنماركي كان
بامكانه ان يختار العيش في هدوء ببلاده
لكن الدم الالماني الذي ورثه عن والده
جعله يلتحق برجاله هتلر لكن وطنيته سقطت
عندما خان نفسه قبل ان يخون بلده ويتحول
لعميل مزدوج لم يتسبب فقط بخساره بلاده
للحرب بل واسهمت عمالته في تغيير العالم
فما قصته ولد ولف ديتريك عام 1911 في
المانيا لابن الماني وام دنماركيه لكنه
نشا في الدنمارك مع والدته التي عادت
لبلدها قبل عام
1914 قبل اندلاع الحرب العالميه الاولى في
الدنمارك درس شميت القانون ورغم انه يحمل
جنسيتها ويعيش على ارضها كانت دم الالماني
يسري في عروقه انضم الى الحزب النازي هناك
قبل ان تعثر عليه وكاله المخابرات
الالمانيه وتعرض عليه التجسس ليوافق دون
اي تردد لم يكن من السهل ان يدخل الماني
الى بريطانيا بطريقه شرعيه فتم ارسال شميت
الى هناك عبر انزال مظلي في عام 1940 حيث
تعرض لاصابات بالغه كما انه سرعان ما وقع
بيد الانجليز الذين جندوه لصالحهم ضمن
نظام دبل كروس الذي تحكمت المخابرات
البريطانيه بموجبه بجميع العملاء الالماني
في بريطانيا وحينها صار يعرف باسم هاري
وليامسون على الرغم من ان اسمه الرمزي
كانت ايت خلال السنوات الخمس التي قضاها
كجاسوس استخدم شميت ايضا اسماء مستعاره لم
يستطع احد حصرها كما شارك في عمليات عديده
كان من ابرزها خطه تمويه مكان عمليه غزو
النورماندي وع خداع العدو حول دقه قنابل
في وان الالمانيه كما نقل اكثر من الف
رساله مشفره عبر الراديو اكثر من اي عميل
اخر في انجلترا اثرت عمالته بشكل خطير على
السلطات النازيه لدرجه ان الانجليز قاموا
بتجنيسه عن طريق الراديو فعاش بعد الحرب
في انجلترا وعمل مصورا لصحف ومديرا
للتصوير كما مكث مع زوجته الانجليزيه
وابنته حتى وفاته في عام
1992 بسبب مرض السرطان كان شمت من اخطر
العملاء المزدوجين تاريخيا لدرجه ان
الكاتب نيجي لويست وصفه في كتابه حول
الجواسيس خيط الخداع بانه واحد من
الجواسيس السبعه الذين غيروا العالم